[APPLAUSE]
GUEST SPEAKER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: What [INAUDIBLE] did
you guys use different color
LEDs?
GUEST SPEAKER: We
used new pixel.
AUDIENCE: To add the color?
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
As well as a couple of
other ones and then we--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
GUEST SPEAKER: Yep.
AUDIENCE: I don't
know if this is
a question you guys
can answer, but do you
guys think that if the paper,
the surfaced in which things
are being projected
through or reflected
is either red, blue, or green,
could you hide some things
and show some others,
you know what I mean?
GUEST SPEAKER: To
an extent, I think.
But it depends also what kind
of material you would use.
AUDIENCE: Right.
GUEST SPEAKER: To
an extent, but it
wouldn't be as effective
as basically using
the codes that turn on and off.
[INAUDIBLE] Yeah.